today we're going to talk about how we
can make a computer CPU run more than
one processor time we said look at the
other side of this just before Christmas
with us how we can have many CPUs one
Rotten program what we want to look at
today is how we can have one CPU appear
to run many programs at the same time we
interrupt this program to bring you how
do we get our operating systems to allow
more than one program or as the
operating system parlance is process run
on the CPU at one time now obviously we
can't but we can use a technique called
multi programming or as it's commonly
referred to in the sort of non computer
science world multitasking to simulate
that effectively what we're doing is
switching between one process and
another very very quickly and the reason
we can do this is because if we think
about how program runs some other time
it is running one instruction than the
next and then the next and the next and
sequence after each other but a lot of
the time the programs often particularly
interactive programs ones we use aren't
actually doing anything they're maybe
waiting for a network packet they may be
waiting for a key to be press or the
mouse to click on a button they may have
just asked the operating system to load
a file from disk they may have just
asked your own system to print out hello
world and so we can use that file
actually these programs are waiting for
the operating system to do something and
the operating system is actually waiting
in many cases for the hardware I mean if
we waiting for a network packet we're
waiting for the hardware to send it to
us or whenever there's another machine
to send it to us so actually the CPUs
not doing anything useful and what we
can do is attempt to say ok this program
is not doing anything useful at this
point let's let something else that can
run run at that point so to start a
process the operating system needs to
load from the sources in the code and
the data for the program into the
computer's memory once this is done we
can start the process and the operating
system does that effectively by just
setting a few bits of stay within the
operate system to the right values and
then we can just jump to that address in
memory where we loaded that program at
this point the CPU is only executing the
process
me and the operating system is frozen
now the C people keep executing the
process forever unless it's tell to do
otherwise
now either by an external interrupts
interrupting the CPU or
I mean the process making a request to
the US so if I trust the OS to print out
hello world I'd call the OS a which
point control is passed back to the OS
which can then handle that request
afterwards the OS done the requests can
pass back control to the process and
things continue the program can run and
run occasionally making calls to the OS
at which point control is passed back to
the operating system and then back to
the process to do more calculation
before passing control back to the OS
when the process wants something else to
happen however the operating system
doesn't need to hand control back to the
same process there's nothing actually
stopping us loading a different programs
coding data again from storage into
memory as well and then we can start
that program instead by returning to its
code start address
welcome to computer files first unboxing
video I've got here the Raspberry Pi for
computer and we're going to open this
and have a look at how this works and to
do that we're going to need to could
open nobody's actually got the knife
modulating an operating system could you
load the knife DLL for me and then the
ice is back in control and it can then
pass control not back to the new process
but back to the original process which
continues as if nothing had happened
it's oblivious to the fact that this
this other process running from my point
of view I asked their eyes to do
something it did it and handed back
control to me and completely unaware
there's any other process running on the
system so we're going to have the
operating system switch between the
different processes and to do that we
need to be able to do three things the
first is we actually need to physically
switch from one processor running to
another now at some level this is
straightforward we just jump from one
memory address to another but we have to
keep track of a few things and so that's
called context switching and we'll look
at that in detail in another video the
other thing we need to do is decide
which process is going to run next and
that's called process scheduling and
again we'll do another video on that
just deciding we've had this process
running which one's ready which one we
gonna actually run at this time and the
other thing is we need a model a way of
deciding
which processes are available to run and
that's what we're going to look at today
so we're gonna have this idea there are
many programs running many processes
running and we're going to switch
between them so let's look at how we
might model that so we're going to start
off building up what we call the life
cycle of the process so we're going to
start off by creating the process and
then it'll transition from that to what
we call the running state and if you
think about surprises is created it then
starts running on the CPU so the
organism cursor is then start running on
the CPU and then eventually it is
terminated so we can start to see how
this work so let's find a process Jadey
baby so the process gets created by the
operating system as we saw in the demo
it then starts running on the CPU and
it's doing things it's calculating
things and this is a very boring process
and it just immediately kills itself and
doesn't I think at some point this
process is going to want to interact
with the rest of the world it's going to
call the operating system to do
something and when it does that we model
that by having another state in our
system call this blocked and our process
can transfer from the running state to
the block state and at that point we
know that process is still doing things
it hasn't finished it can't run at the
moment because it's waiting for
something to happen so we can print it
out some data to come over the network
whatever it is so what we do is it stays
there and then eventually we can take it
back to the running State and so we can
then have our process go back to the
running state it's printed out hello
world it now waits for a key to be press
so it's blocked again and then it goes
back to the running state until
eventually it gets terminated but of
course we can then start another process
and we can start to see now how we can
model having more than one process
what's going on in the operating system
because we've got that process running
there and then we can create another one
now obviously you can't run at the
moment because this process is running
but eventually this process will ask for
some what you've written at which point
it's blocked and the operating system
can shed you'll that process to be
running so this is waiting for say a key
to be pressed on the keyboard
but this one can then run start
calculating PI to 500 decimal places or
whatever it is it's doing now we'll get
to a point where either this process
will decide it's a 1 used to print
something else at which point it can
then become blocked as well or this
process will get the key that's been
waiting for from the keyboard in which
case it's ready to start running again
so actually we don't translate directly
from block to running we actually have a
state called runnable and we use that to
keep track of processes that can run but
can't run at the current time so this
one's running this one can run but it's
not ready and let's create another one
as well so eventually this one starts
saying something out to disk so it's
gotta wait for that to finish and now we
can either showed you this one to be
running or that one could be showed you
to be running and that way that's let's
put that one on there have the green
process running this one gets the data
saved to disk and so that one is now
also runnable and then this one less way
because the network packet it's an HTTP
server say and we can show you one of
these back on here now as should be
obvious you can only ever have one
process or running at a time or
attempting one per CPU but you can have
as many as you like in the runnable
state and you can have as many in the
block state and you can follow the
transitions between the different things
to model the process and this works fine
because eventually the process is can
then finish it complete can you go
straight to terminate from so runnable
or anything do you have to go back to
well so the program the opposite yeah
there's a good question if you're here
could you go straight to terminate yes I
know this process could be too measured
directly by the operating system
something outside it says I want to kill
this process in which case he gets to
make it and cleared up but for you to
stop itself it has to be running on the
CPU to execute the code to say it's
finished so we can have many in this
state many in this state but any one
running on there but then you could have
another CPU come in yeah none of my
processes is missing just wait
yeah I'll need another process of gym
but okay so this works let's have a
running process we move things around
but say this process here something goes
wrong you've written a bit of code and
it gets stuck in an infinite loop well
we've now got a problem the operating
system the way we've designed it can
only switch when one of these processes
hands control to it cause the operators
and that's what they've built it's what
we call a cooperative multitasking
system because we require the processes
to cooperate they have to hand control
back to the pros to the operating system
at some point and operating systems like
the original Mac house of ready systems
like Windows 3.1 they work in this sort
of fashion they could run many programs
at the same time but they required them
to pass control back to the operating
system regularly which a GUI program
will do so the way they work but if they
ever do some long calculations a very
tracings I mean you could often get the
system freeze if it was badly written
software you'd have to call the
operating system occasionally to pan
control back but there is another way we
can do it we can have build what's
called a pre-emptive multitasking
operating them and what happens here is
that the operating system says ok I know
I can switch control when you move
between States when you press control to
me because I can then bring that one in
but what I'll do is I'll say I'm going
to regularly look at what's running and
change the process and to do that we
have another let me just redraw this
diagram before we do that so at this
point if this process is running for a
long time then the operating system
can't change it because it's codes are
not running we were reliant on this
actually making a call to the operating
system now the way we get around that is
a modern operating system like UNIX like
Windows NT and so on what they do is
they say actually as well as switching
processes when they call the operating
system we will let the operating system
switch the process automatically and the
way we do that is two things first we
provide a mechanism for the operating
system to regain control regularly from
the proces regardless of them doing it
and the way we do that is we have an
external interrupt which fires say every
second every thousandth of a second
whatever you want it to be the
difference from computer to computer so
every to hundreds of a seconds this
external timer interrupts the CPU and
that passes control to the operating
system and now the operate systems back
in control and it can switch processes
it can say well okay this process has
now had enough time on the CPU we shall
take that off and put a different one on
and the way it does that is if we extend
this model to allow us to move process
not just from blocked into being ready
to run a ball but from running into the
runnable state so that we can bring
another process in and what happened is
that every time we switch processes we
move one from running in to run a ball
or back into running or occasionally
that one will then call the operating
system who can we move one in like that
so we get some switching as the regular
interrupts are happening between the two
and so on it's like having the two
Steve's talking about different things
and we can keep them running until they
finish and we get to murder them what's
happening we've talked about the keydown
event the key up mouse-click events we
probably wouldn't get one where the
mouse is moving if you think about as
the mouse is being moved you've got lots
and lots of events most of which you're
not interested in you're probably only
interested when a button is pressed or
so on the only times pass that's
different is it cause of you